as members of groups we're always on the
lookout for leaders acting in ways to
portray a sort of selfishness or that's
not regarding other group members as
equal partners and as sort of a group
project we're so quick to want to jump
on leaders that betray selfishness that
maybe they're not displaying most of the
time I think that explains a lot of our
fascination with like the Affairs of
politicians or when politicians say
things that appear to contradict what
they had said earlier we're constantly
in the lookout for leaders that might be
potentially acting not in our interests
what would you say are the interesting
evolutionary questions about human
leadership
uh well first
um
you know
asking an evolutionary question uh about
leadership perhaps presumes that
um it was selected for
so that we've evolved some kind of
motivation to adopt leadership or
followership as members of groups
um
and I think you know the research on
that is still ongoing
um and so it would sort of
require that over our evolutionary
history and ancestral human societies
individuals that had such motivations to
adopt leadership or followership I mean
it takes two to tangle there
um
they their reproductive success was
improved or being just being members of
a group in which leadership and
followership was was happening enabled
their groups to outperform other groups
um but taking an evolutionary
perspective requires us to think about
um over evolutionary time skills where
was leadership and fellowship adaptive
particularly the specific kinds and
unique kinds of leadership and
followership that that humans engage in
um because leadership is fairly
ubiquitous across social species
um but there are some unique properties
in human leadership how so what like
uh well I think first
um there's a lot of active leadership in
humans where you know leaders will talk
directly to other group members to try
and get individuals to coordinate you
know use rhetoric various other
communication strategies to directly
influence the behavior of others in
their group
um now you see instances of that in
other species but I think the majority
of leadership
um in another species and perhaps
majority of leadership and humans too
might be more passive so it's sort of
one individual and does some kind of
action and other members of the group
observe that and decide it's in their
interest to do the same
so it's not like that one that one
leader has actively communicated with
other individuals to get them to do
something like uh a lion decides that
we're gonna try and go after this
particular thing and everybody else
that's in that Pride goes after it as
well exactly yeah that's a good example
okay um I think humans do that too but I
mean I think when we use the word
leadership we're often thinking more of
the active kind
where I'm directing you or giving you
explicit instructions or uh things like
that okay that that is more rare I think
and that's a function of the fact that
we can communicate more deeply I guess
that we can hold different levels of
hierarchy within our minds that people
can be status full at
Scavenging or communicating or fighting
or whatever whereas I guess if you're a
lion it's are you big and powerful yes
no yeah I think I mean maybe what you're
you're you're bringing up is division of
labor like if you're in a group there
might be some people with some skills
that are better than others and
um if solving some group goal or a
problem uh can benefit from a division
of labor certain people do some tasks
and others do others leadership can help
coordinate all that
um and so that kind of division of labor
with coordinated by leadership really
rare and I think that but that is what
makes humans and human groups so uh
incredible at solving problems and
innovating and yeah I suppose that
that's a reason that leadership would be
more important like if you have all of
these different divisions working you
need somebody that is outside of the
divisions to be able to bring them
together to coordinate them toward a
common goal exactly and and even that
aspect of understanding that there's a
common goal I think it's not that common
across species either I think humans are
really good at I can understand that you
have the same goal that I have
right even if that requires you to
engage in some slightly different
Behavior than me we both have some
abstract notion of what the end goal
will be
um and so there's other things that that
I think uh it's not just about
leadership but about sort of other
aspects of our psychology and our
cooperativeness that come into play here
well like certainly leadership is it can
be the sort of glue that brings it
together what other elements are coming
into play
just our propensity to cooperate with
others who are especially those we're
not related to
um and our ability to to just understand
what other people are thinking really
well such that I can create some mental
representation of a goal that I know you
share as well
um our ability to communicate through
language
um yeah all these other things are
important why is it that humans
have
evolved to coordinate with people that
aren't part of their genetic kin
that's you know a huge research program
on that
um
a lot of people will point to
reciprocity where it pays to sort of
help somebody if they'll help you back
um but that's it there's sort of trouble
with reciprocity according to various
models and scaling up to not just
cooperating with non-kin but in large
groups with non-kin
um reputation is another mechanism that
might be really important so humans care
a lot about reputation
um this relates to leadership and
followership as well uh and so uh we're
motivated to cooperate with individuals
we may not know well or
um are related to because it has
ramifications for how other people might
treat us in the future
um or responding to punishment and
reward uh also can be a factor
um
so yeah uh other uh you know more
controversially perhaps others have
argued group selection might play a role
in human cooperativeness meaning
um ancestorly groups of humans that were
more cooperative
out-competed other groups and then their
descendants were as a result more
cooperative
uh by inheriting whatever traits led to
the cooperativeness in the first place
why would it be more in the animal
kingdom and yet prevalent in humans does
that suggest that humans have got more
complex challenges that we need to face
than other animals do yeah uh
I think this is you know
largely speculative still uh are
understanding how all this happened
um I I like to think that a key was a
transition to hunting and Gathering kind
of ecology
where
uh ancestral humans started going after
food that was harder to get
um that place selection on greater
intelligence but also greater
cooperativeness because getting after
going after food it's harder to get you
have to dig up or hunt down or scavenge
um it sometimes requires cooperation
just in the act of pursuing those Foods
or at you know you could pursue it
individually but you might come home
empty-handed such that you're going to
want to share with somebody who could
help you and then another day they might
come home empty-handed and you could
share with them so I think this
transition to hunting and Gathering was
probably key to the shift to greater
cooperativeness greater communicative
ability greater intelligence lots of
things
what ends up determining who becomes a
leader are you able to predict this
yeah so uh
you know there's a lot of long-standing
debate in Psychology about the traits
versus situations
and
um
you know are there in our groups are
there particular things like uh
personality or intelligence or even
things like body size
um that are more likely to
uh cause certain individuals to step
forward as Leaders
um there's an interesting recent paper
that found one of the key things that
predicts leadership is our willingness
to make decisions that could have that
have consequences for others uh even
where we're not certain what those
consequences might be those people that
are sort of less anxious about making
decisions that impact others where
there's uncertainty are more likely to
emerge as leaders
um
so there are lots of traits but also
situations matter tremendously so uh
you know uh for example
um
group members tend to there's a lot of
evidence group members in facing threats
external threats to the group will tend
to look to individuals to help
coordinate who are have
some signs of being more
dominant in their personality
um and so that's been you know these
interesting experiments that ask people
to choose a leader and they're showing
an array of faces and they're given
different situations and in situations
where people are you know are supposedly
members of a group that are being
um
uh confronted with some other group
that's attacking them
people tend to prefer faces of leaders
that look more dominant or have more
sort of masculine eyes kind of faces
um interpreting that is is tricky
um
but uh there's some suggestion that you
know to the extent ancestrally in their
smaller groups individuals who had more
dominant traits uh in face-to-face
groups could more sort of maybe
efficiently or rapidly coordinate others
or are more able to implement
um punishment as incentive to get people
to contribute
um but that you know dominant kinds of
individuals or or traits that are
related to dominance comes with risk
that those kinds of leaders might
exploit you so there's this sort of
trade-off right
um that can be situation dependent
um when a group's facing existential
threats maybe you're less likely to
worry about pursuing a more kind of
dominant leader uh other times you might
want to avoid that yes if you end up
locking in a tyrant just because you had
a brief period of conflict that's going
to be bad long term what are what are
some of the similarities that we have
with other animals are there certain
traits that do seem to be pretty
um scalable pretty similar across
different animal groups and ourselves
so related to this the the potential
contribution of dominance related traits
cues to body size or strength or more
aggressive kind of personality
um in other animals sometimes leadership
is
um
tied to the dominance hierarchy
so who is that the the top of the
dominance hierarchy is more likely to
lead groups to new new directions or
um
uh to act as uh conflict mediators
within groups so you see that in in
other primates that dominant individuals
will sometimes break up fights
um
so that you know and then still looking
in humans yeah to the extent we we have
these preferences for individuals that
have traits conducive to dominance
uh preferences for them as leaders and
that has some sort of
homology with the way that dominance can
contribute to leadership and other
primates and other animals
but there's lots of leaders and other
animals that that are not uh high in the
dominance hierarchy
all right that um
uh individuals that might have some some
specialized kind of knowledge or are
first to move and and this is getting
back to this sort of passive kind of
leadership and the rest of the group
just sort of wants to do the same thing
so
um
you know and and so boldness right kind
of personality of sort of bold
personalities
irrespective of their location the
dominance hierarchy can lead to
leadership and other animals and so you
see that in humans too
um it's not and especially in humans
given that
um we are much better able to
uh
keep dominance from exploding Us by
acting collectively to keep down
dominant individuals so that you know we
might prefer individuals to have some
kind of dominant like traits in certain
situations to help lead coordinate but
we're also very suspicious of that and
able to act collectively to to take them
down if needs to be
what's the difference between uh status
hierarchies and Leadership then does
someone just in a human society rise up
through the status hierarchy and then
get popped out of the top as a leader or
is there a relationship between the two
at all
I think um status hierarchy is like
access to resources so who gets more who
gets less
um
but it can be tricky because leadership
itself could be a contested resource
like because if gaining access to
leadership gets you access to resources
or reputation that improves your mating
opportunities or anything else like that
then leadership itself becomes uh sort
of
um
much more tied to the status hierarchy
um
but leadership I would Define as sort of
differential influence in a group and so
having more influence over
individuals behavior in pursuit of uh
some collective goal
um so it's distinct from your location
the status hierarchy but leadership can
be
the kinds of things individuals compete
over or how in individuals act as
Leaders can influence
subsequently their their status
presumably the leaders would be some of
the highest status people within a group
as well
in humans uh often yes but
um
not necessarily so I think our political
leaders are in a large-scale societies
right uh very good very good example
yeah right
um what about the differences in traits
for leadership in men and women how how
do they uh compete intersexually
differently for that
yeah I mean that's a Minefield of an
issue I think
um I'm of the persuasion that uh
uh men and women can you know can be as
effective uh as leaders that gender per
se doesn't really matter in terms of
leadership effectiveness
but there might be some subtle things
that um
uh
influence how men and women lead right
so that are related to
um
uh our evolutionary history
so to the extent that men are more
willing to compete
um using say physical violence right or
to take outsized risks that can that can
negatively impact health and safety
um then as a product of our of of sexual
selection and um processes that are
other animals like humans have
experienced that can create average
differences in Behavior across males and
females
um that would mean that on average then
sort of male and female leadership in
humans might have a certain slightly
different tenor and that uh
uh at the least would suggest we don't
want you know
we would want lots of women in
leadership and not just men not just for
the sake of equity for its own sake but
that there might be slightly different
approaches to leadership that would be
uh any sort of organization or country
or you know business would benefit from
slightly different approaches to
risk-taking on average
uh approaches to Coalition building
um
and so
yeah I think leadership you know uh by
by men and women is largely the similar
but there can be on these average small
differences that might matter on
aggregate what about the costs and the
benefits of leadership and fellowship
because I think I don't know when people
watch movies that have got a really
strong lead in it that they find
themselves identifying with
you you start to think well that would
be me I would be the the guy that's a
the Gladiator or the Spartacus or the
whatever the to the front of it but it's
not just all positives presumably and
also Fellowship isn't just all negatives
so what are some of the costs and the
benefits of both of those
right so
um can't have too many cooks in the
kitchen or else nothing gets made
um you know say I think that's what
you're alluding to is also it can't you
can't have everybody be a follower and
then nothing else nothing gets done
either so
um they're costing so that's right there
is some of the the benefits of actually
being a follower are that you're a
member of a group that is actually
accomplishing something
um you're able to achieve goals
uh as a member of a group compared to
other groups that have too many people
vying for leadership or too few people
vying for leadership
um
benefits to followership also include
less sort of EX reputational costs from
not achieving group goals
um you're not on the hook for the
performance as much right
um and at the same time you're maybe
gaining experience to in the future
become a leader that's another potential
benefit
um
so yeah
um I think we are all you know I don't
see any people born leaders or followers
rather think we have psychology that
sort of weighs our individual attributes
the situations we're in the other
members of our group how they compare to
us and we're constantly kind of
adjusting who we're deferring to or our
own sort of motivations to try and get
influence others
in strategic ways that's um
sometimes consciously sometimes not so I
don't think you know we're either
leaders or followers but these these
costs and benefits
um play out very dynamically depending
upon how we assess ourselves relative to
others in our groups and relatives to
the situations we find ourselves in the
situation part is really interesting
thinking about the fact that you might
have someone who would be a great leader
in one particular type of ecology or
situation and then 50 years later
something completely different has
happened and that would be the worst
person to choose somebody that's super
risk-taking at a time when you need to
be sort of bold and decisive someone
that's super conservative when things
are going badly and you actually need to
make some changes all of these different
elements yeah that's that's very
interesting that's something I hadn't
considered yeah and relates back to that
discussion of you know this interesting
preferences that individuals have for
dominant kinds of traits when their
groups face sort of existential kinds of
issues
um those same individuals at other times
would not be favored As Leaders
um
what are the Dynamics that are important
for regulating that leader follower
relationship because you know you often
hear about the tumultuous and precarious
leader that is oppressive the Tyrant
that's keeping everybody down but what
are the
um important metrics that are mediating
that
I think he is the the size of the
leader's Coalition so if they have a big
enough Coalition that is benefiting from
their leadership that's that can do the
trick
um but you know I think the more
democratic you get or the smaller the
group size such that leaders really have
to convince most group members of their
benefits I think he is Leader's ability
to display uh what's called procedural
fairness that they're acting in the
interests of group members so even if
outcomes leaders outcomes are the
outcomes of the decisions
uh are not sort of benefiting everybody
equally so long as people perceive the
leaders are trying to treat everybody in
the group fairly
then
um
that's key for leaders gaining
legitimacy and keeping their positions
um and so I think as members of groups
are always on the lookout for leaders
acting in ways to betray a sort of
selfishness or
um that's not sort of regarding others
other group members as equal partners
and as sort of a group project
you know we're so quick to want to jump
on leaders that do things that betray
you know
um yeah kind of selfishness that maybe
they're not displaying most of the time
I think that explains a lot of our
fascination with like in politics
um the Affairs of of politicians or
um when politicians say things that
appear to contradict what they had said
earlier
we're constantly on the lookout for
leaders that might be
um potentially acting not in our
interests
is that because the impact of a leader
that wasn't acting in our interests
would be so outsized that it's super
important that our radar is hyper
attuned to whether or not they are yeah
we just don't want to be cheated I think
um we don't want
leaders to get more than they deserve
um or for them to like lead the groups
and directions that will primarily
benefit them and not other not the rest
of the group
um also I think there's there's uh been
some discussion of the why you know the
fact that we talk about these things too
we communicate about our leaders is a
means of us potentially
establishing the uh Collective action
against that leader should they he or
she act in selfish ways so we're not
only just sort of trying to figure out
as individuals our leaders benefiting us
or acting selfishly we're also
communicating about this others that can
serve as a coordinative device oh did
you see what that leader did the other
day
to help you know in in the instance we
need to act against that leader we can
do so by rallying around some kind of
thing they did oh okay so that's the
gossiping behind the leaders back or the
discussing after the presidential debate
candidate debate or whatever right that
serves a number of functions it probably
stress tests your interpretation of how
that went I thought that he looked
really disingenuous did you think that
he looked disingenuous it probably
starts to create early coalitions in
case you need to do something to push
back against someone that it also would
create a coalition that says I really
liked what he said there about the the
going to get the berries tomorrow or
whatever like let's I feel like we
should support him I've been saying we
should go and get the berries for for
ages yeah
yeah that's really interesting to
consider that the gossip especially
about the leader serves a purpose that
is like externalizing a stress test
about whether or not they are playing
that fairness and cheetah detection game
and also maybe other members of the
group you know disagree with you about
whether the leader's acting selfish so
you're like you're saying that stress
test is
hmm can I get other people to
potentially coordinate with me against
the leader let's see right
um
so yeah uh I suppose as well
that would suggest
that leadership which is primarily done
through like very heavy dominance is
going to be a little bit more fragile if
you don't ever allow dissent in a
relatively small group then people are
eventually going to find a way you're
going to squeeze it so hard that it's
going to come out the sides and people
are going to find a way to have a
discussion outside of earshot of you and
your goons and then eventually those
people are going to Rally together and
then get rid of you right but the hard
part is when you you know your goons
right is key because I don't think
there's any pure dominance you know
leaders can act purely in the basis of
dominance meaning like trying to
dominate everybody else that won't work
oh you know you need two or three people
and then they can physically overwhelm
an individual so it's always the size of
the dominant individual's Coalition can
they provide enough benefits to those
Coalition members that can enable them
to to act more dominantly towards
everybody else
um but once your your Coalition falls
apart then you're done
so yes yeah isn't that there's something
similar to this to do with chimpanzees
as well right the chimpanzees can band
together and then it doesn't matter how
big any one chimp is any three other
chimps can pretty much just rip them in
from limb yeah similar politics I think
but I think what makes humans different
is that we are much better able to form
really large coalitions often with
non-kin and can use them to overthrow
the existing hierarchy rather than like
a lot of those chimp sort of political
coalitions are often just at the top of
the hierarchy they're sort of you know
second third fourth ranking males maybe
coming together trying to work through
the top ranking male rather than you
know the whole bottom three quarters of
the the group coming together
simultaneously having the shared goal
maybe there's even leadership amidst you
know within that bottom three quarters
emerging to orchestrate coordinate to
overthrow the top quarter that's I think
really uniquely human
um what is there anything else that you
see in modern politics that is a
interesting reflection of a an
evolutionary adaptation that you think
that we've got when it comes to our
relationship to leaders and thus
scrutiny and skepticism of them
yeah
um
so yeah I think our outside's attention
to leaders personal lives as sort of
means of trying to assess oh are they
doing things that might be selfish
um
I think there are other things that
reflect maybe our our evolutionary
history of of cooperating and leading in
smaller groups that we see play out in
our large-scale societies
um like the way we organize our leader
fall relationships and often in these
sort of tiered hierarchies we create
these bureaucracies that sort of have
tiered structures that in a sense are
sort of recreating smaller groups at
each level with face-to-face leadership
and followership but those groups are
embedded within larger groups embedded
within larger groups
oh yeah okay so you're saying that um
the fact that you would have a a senate
and within the Senate there's still a
degree of hierarchy within that and then
Downstream from the Senate you've got
the people that they enact and then
Downstream from that and done so you
understand you're nesting small groups
that have more power and then it scales
up and up and up until the one person at
the top right military hierarchy
similarly any sort of you know business
is structured that way uh larger the
larger they get the more likely to adopt
these nested hierarchies
um I think because it facilitates this
face-to-face leader follower interaction
within groups
as well but you know and
in ways that can help and coordinate
decision making
um throughout the much larger group
you know as opposed to say you know
uh several thousand people are part of
some some business you know with no
hierarchy all sort of just reporting to
one leader you know really tricky yes
yes because how would you be able to
there's no Coalition ability it's just
one huge big soup of people that you're
all getting okay
is there anything for us to learn about
leadership from
non-mammal animals I I always think
about
um bees and ants and stuff and you've
got the queen right within this but I
never really hear any parallels drawn
between insects and humans is that
because their development is so
different to ours that basically we're
talking about an entirely different not
only species not only lineage but it
might as well be a different world
and in some senses I'd say yeah that
they have these kind of large colonies
um that are with all kinds of incredible
self-sacrifice That You Don't See in
humans
um
and you know coordination among you know
thousands of individuals that's
happening really fluidly without any
obvious you know bureaucracy right there
might be a queen but Queen's not you
know actively directing things you know
um at the same time then there's also
evidence of like leadership happening
in terms of implementing punishments and
rewards so there's some I think ant
species where this has been shown where
when workers have cheat by trying to
reproduce produce their own eggs
you'll see in some species the queen
will come and uh and Target those
you know individuals for punishment
um
execution
yeah I can't remember what it was if
it's if it's not if it's just like
eating the eggs that they produced or
doing something else
um to the actual ants that did that
um there are other worker worker ants
that will take on that punishment role
um
so yeah
um
they're not just sort of like
you know the Borg but can it can engage
in these sort of smaller
inter-individual dynamics that involve
punishment and reward
um
so that might be some kind of
yeah yeah I I learned from uh Joe Henrik
about gerontocracies
and I'd never heard about those before
have you looked at these
in humans yes yeah
so there are
smaller scale societies hunter-gatherers
particularly in Australia there's
there's several gerundocracies where
it's the oldest of the old males who are
highly polygenous
and are sort of lead the sort of rituals
of the group
um
and what's really interesting about that
is that these are hunter gatherers a lot
of these gerontocracies and so
um often hunter-gatherers you tend to
see less pronounced hierarchy less
polygyny because there's not a lot of
wealth for individuals to monopolize and
you know when when there's societies get
wealthier you often see males will
monopolize that wealth form coalitions
to defend it enhance their opportunities
for poligity
so that you see this in hunter-gatherers
without a lot of wealth it's really
interesting these gerontocracies and so
leadership there
yeah it's concentrated into the older
men
um
I don't know what context did you
discuss it was just I would say with him
I found it interesting that um
he he mentioned young male syndrome is
super prevalent in these particular
types of groups which is you have all of
these young guys who have got high
testosterone and no family and no
partner so why don't they just run
around and cause mischief and stuff like
that and he mentioned that they're
inherently unstable but then how how
would they ever stick about you'd only
ever see them for a couple of
generations and then they'd change so
there must be some degree of stability
it was in a mating context to do with
the fact that these older guys capture
basically all of the women and in order
for the younger men to be able to mate
there's
decades worth of ritual and process and
rite of passage after rite of passage
after something else that they've got to
go through and then eventually finally
they get to earn the rights to mate I I
just I figured that it must be super
fragile and unstable yeah I think the
ways of mitigating that problem are when
you create sort of men's organizations
that are create bonds between this older
and younger men and sort of show younger
men oh there's a pipeline where you can
you know with age and time and
demonstrating your value to the
community you will get to be where I am
um and often you know those often emerge
in more warlike societies so Warfare
becomes that vehicle for the younger men
to establish themselves
um but with these
geritocracies in Australia it's yeah
much more tenuous I'd say because you
don't have these strong men's
organizations
you don't have you know there's Wharf
there's some degree of warfare though
um and this you know one thing maybe
helps is as you just said a lot of
ritualization
um so I don't know it's it's an ongoing
uh debate but there is variation Within
These Australian
um hunter-gatherers that was documented
by anthropologists and so you do see
there is some evidence that there are
higher rates of polygyny that
gerontocracy is more pronounced in those
Aborigines that were living close to the
coast with with sort of denser resources
um
and uh more where resources can be more
controlled
so in a sense it is there is some oh
that's because if the resources were
less available
you would need to have everybody on side
you would have to have everybody working
together as opposed to going against you
why is that the case why is it yeah
one it could
um
reduce the need for cooperation across
individuals in terms of sharing
resources secondly when there's wealth
um is more monopolizable you can defend
certain say
Fisheries or productive soils or
um something or you know Parcels of land
uh those that can do that well can
enforce say polygyny uh enforce their
their leadership on others and so
yeah there's there is that variation
within the sort of these are
intercratics societies where the more
defensible the resources the more
paligent you see the more intense the
gerundocracy
you've mentioned there about the
relationship between local ecology and
the way that hierarchy group structure
leadership gets deployed what what is
there to know there because I didn't
realize until reading your work about
just how much of this is influenced
local resources about just how much risk
there is from outside groups all of that
stuff
I think he is the biggest key I think is
group size so how ecology shapes group
size is is huge so why leadership at all
it says help solve coordination and
Collective action problems you know
groups face trying to solve these
problems they can break down just
because people are able to coordinate
well or you know accomplishing group
goals could break down because enough
people are cheating or free riding on
the on the whole on the everybody else
so those problems just get worse as
groups get bigger
and so if you're in an ecology with lots
of plentiful resources that enables
populations to grow
um you can get uh more conflicts more
coordination failure more free riding
that might create demand for leaders to
help resolve those issues and you as
group memory might even want to endow
Leaders with certain rights and
responsibilities formalized rights and
responsibilities
as groups get larger so group size is
one huge thing that is also dependent
upon the occult the larger ecology
but then also this was just referencing
with the in Australia the more that
there are defensible resources the more
that certain lineages coalitions
um family units can control and defend
resources and then impose a sort of
hierarchy on others
um by controlling access to valued
resources what would an example of
defensible resources be
uh uh so
um uh productive Fishery
like a salmon run I mentioned that
because do you see there are hunter
gatherers in the Pacific Northwest that
are well
uh well studied because they had
um
uh inherited chiefdoms so chieftainships
were inherited they had slavery
um these were hunter-gatherers
um but what the reason that we think
that um they had such intense
hierarchies a lot of really formalized
coercive leadership is because those
leaders could and their families
controlled access to the best fishing
sites
um and so
that that whole sort of the way that uh
resources can be controlled and used to
benefit you and yourself and your kin I
think it's an another channel in
addition to group size that can
influence
the extent of hierarchies and the way
and the extent to which leadership is
formalized and even given coercive
our hat takes on coercive kind of
properties because if the resources were
indefensible then how would you be able
to coerce people could leave more freely
they would be able to go and do what
they wanted but that's also part of it I
mean if you can leave then you could you
leave so it requires resources being
defensible and they're not being great
exit options people are going to stick
around because all right yeah you know
I'm not doing as well as other people in
this group but it's at least it's better
than leaving
so um that exit option is also important
um so I think in the grant the grand
scheme of things that defensibility of
resources is really much more powerful
in driving up the degree of coercive
leadership
um
uh but that you know also the effective
group Size Matters a lot too and just
you know
societies and communities benefiting
from from leadership and higher and sort
of the differentiation of leaders and
followers can also go up with
larger groups
so yeah there's a lot of ways in which I
think ecology matters does that mean
that more defensible resources and
generally more resources overall
increases inequality within the group
yeah typically
yeah I think that there's that tendency
over human history you know um
where the wealthier
uh groups become the more likely you are
to see
certain individuals monopolize Surplus
production or monopolize the resource
base
that generates that wealth
so
yeah I think that's that's
I think rarely the case that you know
um societies get richer it's just you
know automatically distributed across
everybody well I suppose that's kind of
an obvious an obvious question that if
there isn't a surplus what are you going
to capture in order to be able to create
an inequality if everybody is living
hand to mouth there is only the exact
amount that you need in order perhaps a
little bit less than the amount that you
need in order to be able to survive
nobody can start to store anything
everybody's just doing what they can to
get by yeah I suppose that I mean that's
one of the main things that I learned
from uh the sapiens right by uh you've
all know Harare about the fact that up
until whatever 15 000 years ago there's
no opportunity for people to have
massive amounts of inequality because
there's nowhere near enough uh Surplus
resources yeah yeah I I
mean you sometimes these coordination
Collective action problems or you know
um cyclical increases in group size that
might have occurred in hunter-gatherers
might increase demand for more
formalized leadership to help resolve
problems of coordination and Collective
action but really to really kick that up
and make that a more permanent kind of
you know especially coercive kind of
leadership you really need the
defensible resources where
um you know there's Surplus production
that can be defended and used to benefit
you and your coalition
um what does that oh how do you relate
that to the current way that we look at
leadership in the modern world is there
something to be said about
um compartmentalized secretive
information about us not feeling a
degree of transparency between what we
know that our leaders are doing and our
awareness of it and stuff like that is
there any it feels like there might be
some sort of a crossover there
it's just it's
it's strange in our society where you
know I think most people
hugely underestimate levels of wealth
inequality
um
and
you know whether that wealth inequality
is Justified or not I think we tend to
not we tend to see what's around us so
that we compare ourselves to our
neighbors our co-workers and
um I think that tends to be our unit of
analysis as the people we're
encountering face to face
I think were we truly concerned about
you know
um
you know the our country as a whole uh
and the distribution of wealth
um
you know it might be better served by a
clear understanding of just how wealth
is distributed and and I think most
people are not aware of just that the
level of inequality
um do you think that that's the same
both ways round do you think that people
that are incredibly poor uh as unaware
as the people that are incredibly
wealthy
yeah
um but these you know probably but to
the extent that you know we see Urban
environments really concentrate extreme
poverty extreme wealth maybe that people
in urban environments have a better
sense of things actually because you're
driving past or watching people drive
past as you are someone oh yeah that's
interesting okay so what do you think in
your opinion do you think that leaders
are altruistic or selfish are they
motivated by the desire to help or the
desire for power
uh I think you can answer that in an
approximate level and a more ultimate
level so approximately
um do leaders take on leadership roles
because they really feel like they're
being altruistic and helping the group
uh are they doing it for selfish
motivations and like they have designs
to actually enrich themselves and
and then at an ultimate level you know
you could explain even that supposedly
you know consciously altruistic
motivation on the part of leaders uh in
terms of you know
having that kind of motivation over
evolutionary time scales you know might
have been profitable adaptive
um because it enhanced their
reproductive success so
um
that's something I've shown that you
know some of my research even in small
scale relatively egalitarian
hunter-gatherers individuals that have
higher status including have taken on
leadership positions or have greater
influence in community decision making
tend to experience greater reproductive
success
um and so
you know uh at an ultimate level perhaps
that more that pro-social motivation of
leaders can be explained by the sort of
ways that that actually you know tended
to generate positive reputations uh
increase your status
um that kind of thing
so
yeah uh now
so even the case where leaders say take
a huge pay cut or you know or do things
like that to what extent are they still
benefiting otherwise in terms of
reputation or you know in other ways
yeah and I think especially in in the
modern world and presumably this would
have been reflected ancestrally as well
if you go through a period of being the
leader as long as you don't leave
disgraced you have generated a ton of
Good Will and like uh how do you say
vestigial Renown that you can carry with
you until the rest of time so yeah even
though right now for the next eight
years Mr President you will be paid this
small amount of money you know you are
given an unbelievable amount of
opportunities on the other side of that
I mean Nick Clegg who is the former
co-prime minister of the UK only within
the last 10 years is now the global
communications director or something for
Facebook and he's involved in all manner
of of other bits and pieces so yeah I
think uh that makes a lot of sense one
of the interesting uh insights that you
talked about there is this relationship
between uh status and mating success
what did you what did you learn there
other than more status is probably good
for mating success
ah I think because in a lot of the
smaller scale undergatherer societies
are often they're often framed as being
egalitarian and they are a lot of them
very are fiercely egalitarian where
people who brag or try and coerce others
are rapidly put down
um group members will act against them
at the same time having a kind of
displaying a kind of humble leadership
and and providing being generous
um can lead to you getting these kind of
especially among men uh mating benefits
and so
um yeah it just suggests that uh
you know there are motivations for for
gaining influence in any human society
right and any in a society no matter how
egalitarian there there is hierarchy
however subtle however camouflaged
um that produces can produce these
reproductive variation maybe not in a
lot of modern scale societies
um with you know contraception
um with uh socially imposed monogamy
um uh smaller family sizes in general
but uh at least the evidence that I've
I've gathered suggests that you know
ancestrally even in relatively
egalitarian societies is likely the case
that
um
influence leadership had reproductive
benefits on aggregate yeah so you might
end up with uh better mating success in
the modern world but not necessarily
translate that into reproductive success
with some of the boundaries that we've
placed in between the the Act and the
outcome or even maybe maybe not even
mating success either but uh what you do
have is that reputation that maybe
ancestrally would have translated more
readily into Manning success and
reproductive success so people still
choose to seek it
regardless of whether or not it's going
to cause okay yeah that's that's
interesting
what about
if it was a female leader or a female
that had a lot of dominance did you ever
look at the relationship between female
status and reproductive success
yeah there's not as much good evidence
there
um in part because a lot of sort of male
influence and politicking is just much
more obvious
than uh an overt than other than women
sort of politicking and and Coalition
formation and that kind of thing
um also you pronounce gender divisions
of labor and especially in some of these
smaller scale societies like I work with
um and so uh yeah what evidence I do
have of women's status in terms of
popularity or influence there is some
evidence that it's more women
translate that status more into
um child survival and sort of family
welfare on average relative to males
um not that males don't do that but
women are more likely to we're and in
comparison men are more likely to
translate their status into mating
opportunity
relative to women not that women don't
do that but you know they're these
slight average differences and so
what evidence I have seen including some
I've done with the group I work with and
the Amazon is that
um suggests motivations for acquiring
status and specifically for requiring
leadership might differ on average
across the the sexes
um
but there are lots of motivations for
acquiring leadership but this this
fundamental sort of mating motive and uh
might differ yeah does is there a
difference in mating success when status
is taken from dominance
compared with when status is taken from
prestige
uh good question
um so
I I did find some evidence in the in the
in the group I work with in the Amazon
that status
uh based more on dominance
relate to fighting ability
um
impacts where people have success just
like status related to sort of like uh
freely accorded influence that people
give to somebody they they perceive as
prestigious that in both cases
um this was a study of men uh men had
greater mating success
um and more extramarital Affairs as well
um but for uh I think there was a
difference though in terms of
um agent marriage so the route you get
to that mating success differs where I
think it was
and I could be confusing this but uh the
more prestigious individuals more likely
to get married at younger ages
um
and so there's some slight variation
there
um
but nothing I would hang my hat on got
you and what about the sex ratio how
does the sex ratio within a a group
change roots to power
um dominance versus Prestige as being
the tools that are being used and are
there any other interesting things about
the sex ratio
yeah
um
so that's a you know a good question
something I I want to think more about I
think the what's known about sex ratio
effects on our Behavior Uh suggests that
many where there's many more men
um you can get greater competition among
men
um because they are
you know more there's more competition
for mating opportunity
um at the same time there's also
evidence that with you have a lot more
men when men do form Partnerships
uh with women they're much more likely
to be respectful and
um less domestic violence and because
they're sort of you know the fact if you
lose that partner you're then out in the
sort of baiting game again so it's
really risky to
um
I think where men are in the minority
you get
um
uh
men are more willing to to sort of
pursue shorter term mating goals
they can drive that uh The Mating Market
because they're they're sort of in
um got greater influence given their
small numbers
so I think yeah to the extent when the
sex ratio is skewed more towards women
there are few men and men's mating goals
can predominate in the sort of mating
Market
um men might be more likely to pursue
leadership and status
for those aims particularly to just
enhance their remaining opportunity
perhaps even more explicitly that might
be a prediction I think that's
interesting what would be a reason
ancestrally about why there would be a
skew in a sex ratio at all like men and
women ish are born at around about 50
50. yeah what would be some of the
things that would have caused there to
be a significant skew in that could you
think
um High rates of homicide
Bruce set especially given that our
homicide is more likely to involve males
than females
um so there were skewed sex ratios for
example in
um Inuit populations
where adult males were more likely to
die
um violent death
and and then there's also infanticide
that um
uh also affects things so because the
veils were more vital death
um
they were also there was also a lot of
female infanticide because males were
sort of valued sort of producers and
were more rare and so
you could get this then skewed sex ratio
were there many more men
um that could then exacerbate the sort
of male male conflicts later in life and
sort perpetuate that kind of oh so women
would have after birth
disposed of a female baby right wow
those are two main mechanisms I think is
adult mortality and then infanticide
earlier in life where it's selective by
gender
would um into group conflict play a role
here would there be a potential of
um I guess a proliferation of women
might be if your tribe went and killed
all of the men in another tribe and then
took all of those women I don't know how
common that would be
okay I mean I think the frequency of
warfare in hunter-gatherers and
especially an ancestral human
hunter-gatherers is debated
um certainly homicides are frequent
um but uh yeah I think I think my view
is that Warfare has played a selection
pressure in human psychology for
you know a long time
um
and yeah to the extent that can create
skewed local sex ratios you know because
our psychology does respond to
differences in sex ratio that suggest
that ancestrally we experience variation
in saturations uh that is so interesting
so yes it would have to come from
somewhere yes dude I love that I love
that I love the fact that the only
reason that we're able to respond to
this is because previously we would have
been exposed to it I mean you could
argue some kind of like well you could
reason your you know you find yourself
in some sex ratio and you could sort of
use some kind of logic or Reason to
suggest oh maybe I should adapt my
mating psychology not you know but
um
you know I I'm persuaded that you know
Evolution has shaped our psychology such
that it's responsive by Design to
variation and sex ratio dude that's that
is really really cool look Chris Von
Ruden ladies and gentlemen if people
want to keep up to date with the stuff
that you do why should they go on the
internet
Google Chris Von Ruden look for my
Google sites website I got some papers
and talks and public popular articles
and stuff up there so look for me there
Chris I appreciate you thank you what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]